So let's look at these two representations again a little carefully.
Now, typically to do any kinds of processing we would actually require us to
be able to create a discrete representation of a matrix like this.
So something like this can be converted into a matrix, as I've shown before.
Of course I'm just showing you a six by six part of this.
But basically this entire thing would be represented as a matrix.
And what we would be doing is,
basically we're trying to sample the two dimensional space into a regular grid.
In this, the regular grid are basically columns and rows.
And that allows us to be able to now look for
values that we can actually start looking at as we traverse through.
So I can start counting down in raster scan format,
going down the axes this way, and wrapping around.
And basically, in essence, what it means is now we have a matrix,
just like I showed before, of integer values ranging from 0 to 255.
Now my goal is to give you a bit of an intuition of what this image looks like.
And what are the kinds of things within it.
Again, let's take of this black and white or grayscale image.
And I'm going to now both again zoom into right box here, but
also kind of show you this image in few different ways.
So the first video I'm going to show here is basically the height map
of this image.
If you look at it as it's being rotated around,
you can actually see the pixel values that I was referring to earlier.
And these peaks and
valleys kind of show again that the intensity values of the image
have various types of statistics associated with it, and by playing around with
those statistics we can actually do a lot of interesting things to images.
Now I'm going to show the same thing, for this sub-image, again zooming in.
Now here again you notice the, gray and
the white regions which we have seen before.
And now in this video which you see basically,
as I rotate around that basically see some of the details.
And also the, the ridge, that shows up between the, the hill and
as we go towards the value which is again the lower values of gray here.